hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast humanized in SG mice for
evaluation of immuno oncology
therapeutics
I'm Judy Oracle a Burks and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by lab routes comm
the leading social media site for
science professionals and sponsored by
the Jackson Laboratory the Jackson
Laboratory is a leading provider of
cancer mouse models and in vivo oncology
services and it is a National Cancer
Institute designated Cancer Center
trying on decades of mouse based
oncology research experience the Jackson
laboratory provides capabilities around
model selection and husbandry and
customizable oncology studies to help
clients and researchers evaluate novel
anti-cancer therapies the Jackson
laboratories diverse oncology study
protocols range from traditional
xenograft services to patient derive
xenograft cancer models and advanced
humanized mouse models for immuno
oncology drug development they have the
flexibility to customize studies and
import client provided mice and cancer
cell lines for more information please
visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor the
presentation window and typing in your
comments and questions we'll try to get
to as many as we can and we'll follow up
if we don't have time today
want a better look you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you can't hear or
see this presentation properly let us
know by clicking on the support button
at the top right or use the Q&A button
we'll make sure we try to resolve any
issues now let's get right to today's
presenter we are proud to welcome Brian
Soper PhD technical information
scientist at the Jackson Laboratory dr.
Soper has worked
the Jackson Laboratory for 20 years he
conducted research on treatment
strategies for a mouse model of human
enzyme deficiency approaches included
enzyme replacement gene therapy and
neonatal allogenic bone marrow
transplantation as a technical
information services scientist his area
of expertise is in modeling and
complications associated with human type
1 and type 2 diabetes and research with
immune deficient mice I will now turn it
over to dr. Soper
okay
wonderful thank you thank you for
everyone for joining us I'm gonna go
over a few different things let's begin
with a presentation outline we're going
to begin with an overview of the in
addition enemy owed efficiency of the
nod skip gamma Mao so you cannot
understand in detail why this is such a
more important animal and why it makes
itself amenable to the great research
that we're going to be providing you
information on today then we'll talk
about the humanization of that animal
and this is in the context of
transplanting human on that a poetic
compartment into the mice we'll talk a
little bit about the human immune
function and what's known and then we'll
talk about the application of
patient-derived xenograft and the NSG
and then we're going to combine the
humanization with the patient-derived
xenograft platform and talk about in the
oncology in the humanized mice so let's
begin with an overview of the
immunodeficiency of the NSG lice so
what's very important about this model
is the genetic background the genetic
background contributes a great deal to
this model it's called an OD which
stands for non obese diabetic this
genetic background is actually a mouse
model ended up itself without the
mutations that I'll explain in just a
moment it's a mouse model of autoimmune
type one diabetes
however if you put these other alleles
that we're going to talk about on to it
it becomes even or deficient and no
longer develops the autoimmune
dysfunctions so it has an absence of
hemolytic comment complement reduced
dendritic and macro South macrophage
cell function it doesn't mean that it's
devoid of these cells the cells are
there but if you compare their function
to a black sick sort of Delp see for
example they just don't have the same
level of response now another allele
that genetic background contributes
that's very important is an allele
called SERP Alpha SERP alpha will engage
cd47 on the donor cells and tissues that
are being transplanted into the mouse
now if you were a black six or a biopsy
those certain alleles would cause the
macrophages in those animals to be
activated in phagocytosis human cells
preventing good in graffman however in
the and OD mouse mr. Bellefleur wheel
does not engage them in a way that
activates the magnifier so this X's that
don't eat me signal so it makes things
mice more permissive for the receiving
of these zeno genetic cells and
transplants then of course there's this
kid mutation that has been bred onto
this genetic background skid stands for
severe combined immunodeficiency and
prevents the development of maturity
cells and pees b-cells this is a DNA
repair side of vdj rearrangement the
injera arrangement or recombination is
necessary for the functional maturation
of t-cell b-cell receptors so if you
knock out that rejoining aspect of that
vdj rearrangement those cells cannot
become functionally mature the next
mutation that was bird on to it was the
aisle two receptor gamma chain this is a
complete null of the common gamma chain
the common gamma chain is part of
multiple cytokine receptors
these include interleukin 2 4 7 9 15 and
21 and many of these receptors are very
important for blocking a natural killer
cell activity you may be familiar with a
regular non-skid Mouse without the aisle
to a gamma chain mutation those my still
have natural killer cells and serve as a
very poor recipient for a metaphoric
engraftment
now because the Skibbe tation is on the
DNA repair side of v2j rearrangement if
you're putting tumors into the flank of
these mice and testing chemo therapeutic
agents the host animal itself will be
sensitive to those genotoxicity so keep
that in mind
so if we go back and look at the
different arms of images to understand
all the aspects of you know immuno
incompetence in this mouse we have the
two arms we have the innate arm and we
have the adaptive
and if you look at the nightscape gamma
mouse if we look at all the areas that
are lightened in this model we can see
that there's multiple in there
deficiencies of these animals the
complement system macrophages natural
killer cells on the innate arm and on
the adaptive side we have the B cells -
t-cells and ability to make antibodies
reduced and Hritik cell function and of
course because of the auditory gamma
chain we have cytokines that are
dysfunctional in terms of the cytokine
receptors which are the crosstalk
between the innate and the adaptive ions
of immunity so let's go through now
moving on now we understand the host
Mouse let's talk about the humanization
of the NSG man-animals itself so if you
are familiar with the literature of
humanization of the mice through this
methodology you'll see that the original
publications by dr. schultz and dale
Greiner at all they used neonatal
recipients the me male recipients were
injected into cardiac or inter hepatic
Lee now as you can imagine this is a
makes it a challenge in terms of collie
management you have to do time
pregnancies producing the in male mice
injecting those animals within 24 to 48
hours after birth and then returning
those animals to the mother hoping the
mother will reset accept them now what
we've done in our in vivo services group
is modified that to a more simple
platform where we take three week old
animals and simply do an IV tail vein
injection so that we get all the animals
that are going to survive and becoming
grafted to the cells as you can imagine
we're the most primitive stem cell
compartment the cd34 positive cells and
so all of the mature cells are missing
and so you put in these primitive
metabolic stem cells and they need to
differentiate out into the periphery so
it's good to take 12 to 15 weeks before
those cells are detectable in the
peripheral blood in those animals and we
can validate that by flow cytometry now
just to set you up for those of you who
are not familiar with all the different
aspects of meta polices and the
different cellular markers I'm going to
show you this diagram very briefly here
so of course in bone marrow contain
of the developing kinetic compartment
within the marrow space along the
periosteal surface you can isolate the
hematopoietic stem cells and those are
recognized by a cell surface molecule
called cd34 now within that compartment
there are some cells like downstream
progenitors that also Express cd34 so
basically what you're doing is you're
enriching for the stem cell compartment
if you positively select for those cells
but you'll notice that the other thing
that you'll do is you also eliminate
other cells like these mature myeloid
cells and mature lymphoid cell
compartments and that's a good thing
because you don't want too much
functionally mature T cells in there
because those functionally mature T
cells can recognize the host is foreign
but what you can also do is use these C
34 markers as a way of validating that
you have the development of these
downstream lymphoid and myeloid cells
generated from the primitive an aprotic
stem cell compartment and the hallmark
for getting the stem cell engrafted is
multi lineage engraftment so taking a
look at this paper here one of the
earlier papers on the QC 34 engraftment
in the NSG mice we're looking at
multigrain engraftment so we're using a
series of antibodies to label cells from
the peripheral blood bone marrow and
spleen of these animals which are
conjugated with fluorescent molecules
and we can look in the bone marrow the
spleen and the peripheral blood and what
we can do is look for a pan leukocyte
marker called cd45 so we can get total
engraftment in these different
compartments by looking at human cd45
versus mouse cd45 and then we can ask
within that cd40 for human cd45
compartment how many of those cells are
T cells B cells and myeloid cells so in
these diagrams here we're looking at the
different cell populations in each one
of these dots represents an individual
Mouse that's been engrafted so overall
we see high-level engraftment and all
three of these somatic compartments and
we have representative cells from
so not myeloid and lymphoid compartments
indicating that there's multi lineage
with population in the recipients now
the other thing that I'd like to point
out very briefly in the next series of
slides is that there is slightly
differences from one donor population to
the next so it's very important that if
you set up a cohort of these animals
that you validate them you validate them
for total level of engraftment because
there are going to be slight differences
so the next series of slides is looking
at the different adequate compartments
and we're going to look at the bone
marrow spleen in the peripheral blood
and then on the x-axis what we're going
to do is we're going to look at the
different populations of cells and as
you would expect there's going to be
different levels of your population for
different cell types depending on which
compartment you're looking at and of
course in a bone marrow you're going to
see mostly myeloid cells and less
lymphoid cells so if we go to the next
slide we're going to look at the spleen
and as you would expect you're going to
see a lot more lymphoid cells in
graffman
in this compartment and then finally in
a peripheral blood is also going to be
more of the lymphoid cells but you're
also going to see the myeloid cell
compartments represented as well so
let's talk about the onion function in
these animals so again we're going to
break this down into both innate
immunity and adaptive immune functions
in these recipients so let's look first
at the myeloid cell compartment if you
take the engrafted cd34 mice and you can
pull these human cells out of different
tissues like the lung and the bone
marrow and if you put them in liquid
culture and expose them to fluorescently
labelled beads and ask kendall cells
phagocytosed those beads you can
particularly if you increase the
temperature to 37 degrees Celsius you
can see that these cells will take up
these fluorescent beads whether or not
they're derived for from the lung or the
bone marrow and you can run me cells for
a flow cytometry the leaf fluorescing
you can also look at them
microscopically and you could look at
those cells close up and see if they fed
us a toast those beads
now the other thing you could do is you
could do an in vivo assay and you can
look for the production of
pro-inflammatory molecules after
injecting the mice with little
polysaccharides lippel polysaccharides
are molecules in the cell surface of
bacteria that can be isolated and you
can inject those into the bloodstream
the animals and then you can test for
human specific pro-inflammatory
molecules and as you can see here
there's a number of human specific
pro-inflammatory molecules that are
progressively produced over time after
you inject those mice and it's very
important to note that these molecules
are interacting with toll-like receptors
to a tlr-2 and tlr4 which are found on
the surface of these myeloid cells and
certainly these cells are expressing
teal or foreign to kill or to and kill
at four and then as a functional asset
you can take these myeloid cells that
have been isolated from these mice put
them in liquid culture expose them to
interferon gamma and you can see these
myeloid cells actually phagocytosis and
kill Salmonella bacteria they do have
functional myeloid cell compartment so
the next interesting question in a very
popular cell population of the natural
killer cells now there's a little bit to
understand about the natural soil killer
cell compartment within these nice yes
those cells can be found there you can
see them at about one to three percent
of spleen and about seven percent of the
lung but if you'll notice the markers
there c3 negative and KP 46 positive but
the majority of those splenic NK cells
are going to be C D 56 negative C D 56
is a marker for functionally mature
natural killer cells so there is a
limitation these natural killer cells
are there but they may have some
limitation in their function and their
functional maturity now you can get
these cells to become functional not
mature by introducing things like aisle
15 aisle 12 and poly icy treatment and
what we're showing here on the right is
an in vitro assay where target cells
cells mainly like the k562
or our seating em cells these are cells
that Express markers that are recognized
by natural killer cells in what you
could do is put them in liquid culture
along with the natural killer cells and
you can introduce other molecules within
that liquid culture like poly I see in a
look at 12:00 and IO 15 and you can
measure the supernatant for things like
interferon gamma production or
production of a marker called CD 107 CD
107 is a marker for degranulation which
is an indication that these cells are
attacking and killing these cells in
what you'll notice first here is if we
look at the red arrows that I'm showing
here just to the left of the box is that
with media alone you can get some
indication that the natural killer cells
are able to attack the u5 k562 cells and
the CNO cells but the ability of these
cells to recognize and kill these cells
is enhanced if you look at the area next
to the blue arrows nor indicate that
assists indicates that inner looking in
part 12 and 15 combination poly IC
enhances the up regulation of 50 to 56
and you can enhance killing of those
cells here's an indication that there's
very robust T cell activity in these
mice so if you isolate the T cells from
the spleen of these engrafted mice and
then isolate clonal populations take
these clonal populations of cd4 and cd8
t-cells and expose them to target cells
that are loaded with chromium so this is
a Clemmy and release assay and the T
cells are mixed with these chromium and
loaded target cells at different ratios
as shown by the x axis down here and so
if the T cell is killing the target cell
you're going to get release of chromium
which is what we call a percent
cytotoxicity then what you can do is ask
questions about the specificity of this
killing by mixing an antibody
now cd4 T cells recognize their targets
in the context of MHC class 2 molecules
so if you add an MHC 2 molecule antibody
that blocks MHC 2 molecules you should
see a reduction in killing in indeed you
see a reduction in killing within these
senior clones as shown here if you
include a antes senior excuse me an
empty class one monoclonal antibody you
don't have any reduction of killing and
if you have sinja native targets
included in a syn generic target a non
intelligent amp target you shouldn't
have any killing and indeed you do not
and the corollary is true for the cd8 T
cell clone CDA Sligo toxic T cells
recognize their targets in the context
whether make C class 1 molecules so you
add antibodies of black class 1 you
don't see any reduction in killing you
that class 2 molecules so what you see
is specific killing by these different T
cell populations and of course if you
also sensitize the mice with dnt dnt bia
d NB f which is Dinoco fluorobenzene you
can do to sensitization of these mice
and then come back in with a challenge
after sensitizing the immune system you
can get a pro-inflammatory response and
the ear pinna and this is indicated by a
pro-inflammatory response here and if
you add engines like hydrocortisone then
you have a decrease swelling indicating
that you have delayed type
hypersensitivity responses and you can
test for immunomodulatory as for those
now one thing that i would like to point
out which is a little bit of a challenge
with a model which is an active area of
research is that there are lots of b
cells that are being produced in these
mice but their overall b cell responses
are somewhat limited and this is shown
here b-cells when challenged will
initially make in IgM response they need
to form
germinal centers where they can interact
with follicular dendritic cells and
other important
skills for the functional maturation to
become plasma sight toy or long-term
memory B cells undergo class switching
and produce a lot of IgM and other IgE
molecules like IG median IgA these mice
as shown here in the graphic have a very
good IgM production but have very
limited IgG production as shown here in
the gray okay so that is one limitation
of the model none of what you cannot
immunize them and make lots of human
specific IgG long term stable antibodies
okay so let's talk a little bit about
patient-derived xenograft
testing in these animals and this would
be first alerted is this in the context
of non-human eyes dentistry mice what I
like to point out to you is the Jackson
Laboratory has created a large database
of these a patient derive xenograft
models essentially what we're doing is
we're taking a patient derived two
minutes that are removed surgically
within 24 hours they're placed into the
NSG animals that placed into the flank
of the animal if they grow then we
harvest those tumors and we collect a
bunch of genomics data on them gene
expression profiles we collect a library
of information about the patient history
etc and what is showing in this graphic
here is a distribution of the different
models that we have we have a number of
different models and so we're going to
show you next is how to take a look at
some more information about those this
is a tumor mouse tumor biology database
that we have up on the webpage you can
get through this you can get access to
this by something called the mouse
genome informatics website and there's a
mouse for pure biology search for Mouse
tumors but in the lower corner of that
there's a place where you can click on
is shown by the red box here that leads
you out to the PX model search which is
the patient drive tuners and this is the
interface that you're going to see here
you can search this database by two more
ID if you know it primary tumor type
the diagnosis gene variants if you're
looking for specific tumors with
specific genetic modifications a
mutation to cetera you can do that and
also there's other ways you can search
by indication etc if you Turk if you
search by bladder cancers for example
you get a long list of bladder kits or
models here and if you select one
specifically based by the tumor model
number that will take you out to an
individual page where if we have
standard of care treatment growth
characteristics and other genetic data
associated with that tumor model you can
access it here so one example of this
gene expression profiles we've looked at
a number of genomes the genes are
compared to one another in terms of
generating a Z profile so you can look
at high expressing and low expressing
genes you can also look at other genes
in terms of their high expressing genes
down expression copy number variation
things like that so it's a wide range of
genomics data that you can find with
regard to these specific tumors so what
I'm showing here is a little bit of
information about maintaining the tumor
heterogeneity because one of the
advantages of the px models is that they
are heterologous tumors and we trying to
keep these at very low passage numbers
so they resemble the original patient
derived tumor as much as possible so if
we look in the upper corner here we have
the tumor model number TM 0 0 186 but we
also seen PT that indicates the patient
tumor histology so this is prior to
engraftment into the flank of a mouse p0
is the histology of the tumor and after
being passaged once and then we have the
p1 tumor and the p2 tumor and
essentially what this is showing you is
the titular maintains its overall
histological appearance orbit passage in
the tumor now what's interesting is this
particular tumor has a specific k-ras
mutation and it's normal for the
epidermal growth factor receptor
and this genetic combination would
predict that this model has a specific
reaction to known standard of care drugs
specifically it would be sensitive to
cisplatin and resistant to the drug or
latinum and so if you put this tumor in
the flank of the mouse and we treat
these mice with these agents you will
see that in black we see that this is
the vehicle control group you'll see me
this is the vehicle control this is the
allotment this is the tumor volume over
time treated with a lot nib and you see
that there's no regression of the tumor
and if we treat those tumors with
cisplatin you see what we call
stabilization of disease in this model
which indicates a very robust response
to the chemo therapeutic now just to
show you one more example of that this
is a particular patient that showed
acquired tyrosine kinase inhibitor
resistance now what's being shown in
this graphic here is that the flat line
shown here is this is a time course of
pure development in the patient each one
of these bumps that you see here is an
increase in tumor burden so this patient
had height tumor burden and they were
placed on a latinum and the patient
responded quite nicely which showed a
regression of tumor volume in the
patient unfortunately this patient also
became resistant to that standard of
care treatment and tumor burden returned
the patient went to the clinic some of
that tumor was collected and was passed
on to our patient dr xenograft
library and that's when we received a
tumor the patient went on to receive a
dual therapy and you could see that this
patient was treated with his dual
therapy and then became responsive
fortunately to that therapy so what we
did is we took these tumors and place
them into the mice and to see if they
respond identical to the original
patient derived tuna
they were resistant to a lot nib and
responded to the dual therapy
a fat nib instatox a map shown here so
what the take-home message of this is is
that these tumors very nicely
recapitulate the responses to
chemotherapy agents the same way that
they do in the clinic so let's move on
to our most recent data and this is
using in oncology in the humanized mice
this is combining the humanized mice
with putting tumors on board to develop
a humanized tool bearing knives so you
shoot eyes the mice as we've talked
about already using CDs 34 hematopoietic
stem cells then we put a tumor on board
and this is the tool barring humanized
animals okay so what was interesting is
the original thought was if we talk to
everyone within the immunological
community the original thought was that
well if these tumors are not matched and
you do have a functional immune system
in these mice the HLA mismatch in the
functional immune cells are just going
to reject it tumors and the tumors are
going to wipe be wiped out by the immune
system so one of the first questions we
wanted to ask was well what is the
influence of HLA matching and
mismatching in these mice does it make
any difference in count of tumors grow
the other thing is if we could get these
tumors to grow in these mice would they
respond to chemo therapies like they did
previously or would this change how they
functioned and if we do get them to grow
will they respond to standard of care
checkpoint inhibitors and so I'm gonna
show you next the data that we have
accumulated with regard to all of these
questions okay so the first set of data
that I'm showing you here is a
comparison to non humanized NSG mice
shown in green to the humanized mice
shown in the red square so it's green
circles and red squares and we're
looking at the humanized mice so that's
non humanized mice and when you have
three different patient derived tumors
we have a breast
alone in a soft tissue carcinoma and
we're just simply comparing the growth
characteristics of these tumors in these
two different platforms side by side
and overall take-home message of this is
is that these are not HLA match between
the DOMA traumatic cells and the tumors
would make no attempt at matching them
or so ever and we have a hundred percent
tumor take rate in both these models and
the growth rights are very very similar
and so we were very surprised by and
very excited by this data so the next
question is well what's going on here
are the immune cells that would
established in those humanized mice
entering those tumor sites so we also
harvested those tumors after we did
these girls characteristic studies and
harvested those met what excels and
staying for those cells by full
cytometry so one very important question
also answered here in you should be
aware of is that if you take a patient
derived tumor the original patient
derived tumor can have passenger
leukocytes that go along with it but as
you passage those tumors within mice
they will move those passenger
leukocytes completely so if we look at
the green circles shown here and if we
stain these different tumors for cd45
positive cells we will see that the
non-human eyes mice
the tumors pulled back out of those non
humanized mice there are no human
specific cd45 cells in there at all but
if we look at the humanized mice there
are indeed human derived lymphocytes etc
within those tissues and so at least
seems T cells are actually going into
the tumor sites and are being rendered
energic okay so the next question we
wanted to ask was as I said do they
respond to standard of care treatments
and this is a tumor this is a excuse me
I forget which one which kind of tumor
this was that was placed in the animals
and this is a carcinoma and it was a
treated with a 5-fu and a Basten and
then asked if we could get a digression
of tumor growth and indeed we do see a
regression of tumor growth and we got a
statistically significant significant
reduction in tumor volume using
5f u so the tumors can respond to a
standard of care chemo therapeutic
agents here's yet an additional study
and this is an additional study where we
looked at the response of a breast
carcinoma this is a triple negative
breast cancer
TM BC breast cancer number 1126 and in
this particular case we treated the mice
with either cisplatin or an immuno
modulatory drug called ke true de this
is katroo really is a an antibody that
binds PT one on T cells
now when PD one binds PL one its
receptor on cancer cells that is a
immunomodulatory pathway which shuts
downs the activity of those T cells in
this particular antibody called Katrina
when you flood the system will bind to
PD one of the T cells block that module
immunomodulatory pathway and allow those
T cells to become active and no tumor
aggression or cytotoxic killing all
those cancer T cells and so what we're
showing here is the vehicle put treating
control in the black they can treat it
in the in the red here and then down
here is the cisplatin treated animals as
well so we've got standard of care
response and we've also got indication
of even a modular toric drugs showing
that blockage of to regulate tumor grows
in this animal so we also looked at the
tumors within these mice to seeing your
L R they're actually human derived T
cells entering these tumor sites and yes
of course we've got total human c-45
cells as compared we've got as the
vehicle control group compared to the
control treated group in this particular
experiment that was not enough tumor
volume left in the cisplatin treated
group to actually look for the T cells
within those those tumors so we're
looking at total cd45 so total humans T
total human lymphoid cells
within the tumor site itself and then we
looked at within that c-45 compartment
what kind of T cells and other cells
would have there and we found that we
had human derived b-cells seen for
positive T cells T helper cells and
cytotoxic T cells all found within the
tumor sites of these mines so we also
wanted to do is take a look at whether
we can use combinatorial therapies to
get a response in these animals so in
this particular experiment we're looking
at a lung patient-derived tumor and
we're looking at a combination therapy
of Katrina and docetaxel now
unfortunately we didn't really get a
common tutorial effect if you look at
this data initially it looks like the
combination therapy does the taxol plus
Katrina as shown here by my hair oh it
looked like there was a greater
prevention of tumor growth unfortunately
what you also will notice in the Katrina
vinoth alone is that there's a lot of
standard deviation is indicated by the
arrow bars and that's because there was
one outlier animal in that growth there
was one animal that did not respond to
katroo - in that group there was and
there's an end of ten in all of these
study arms so if you take out that one
non-responder you'll see that the two
lines will overlap one another so what
we're doing now is looking at further
studies where we're trying to get the
minimal effective dose and so we can
look at some kind of a combinatorial
dose response but if we look in these
tumor sites once again and we look for
human derive how many poetic cells we
can see that in all these cells that all
of these tumor sites regardless of
treatment whether it's vehicle alone
Katrina alone or the combinatorial
therapy we say similar frequencies of
human derived from a poetic cells
entering those tissue sites now if we
take a closer look and look at the
histopathology of these and we stain for
human cd45 in green humans cd8 T cells
in red
in cytokeratin which is a marker for the
cancer cells human specific cancer cell
tissues within these sites with these
lung derive tumors we don't see very
many cd8 t-cells within these Saito
character and positive regions at all so
we think that the T cells are kind of in
the stroma or in the margins of the
tumors but when you this is the vehicle
country to treated controlled tumor
group now interestingly of nothing to
contribute treating tumors and you look
at the red areas it looks like what's
happening to us is that the CA is
positive cytotoxic T cells are moving
from the stroma areas or from the
periphery of the two men it can be found
directly associated with the cytokeratin
positive regions of the tumors so the T
cell numbers don't appear to be changing
but the location of those T cells in the
tumor sites do seem to be changing and
so we're going to be collecting some
more data to specifically address the
actual T cell numbers this is just
percentages of human cd45 cells within
the tumor sites so one of the other
questions that we've been asked as well
you know the myeloid compartment is a
very important factor there's myeloid
derives suppressor cells there's tumor
drives suppressor cells called tans
there's a number of different cell
populations obviously the immune system
has strong interactions with the innate
and it will excuse me with the adaptive
immune arm and people are looking I'm
also interested to understand the role
that the myeloid cells play in these
tumor microenvironment myeloid cells can
produce growth factors to stimulate
growth of the vascular system etc so one
of the things we've started looking at
is a new platform for immunization
called the NS g SG m3s gm3 stands for
mice that also which are essentially
Etta streamlines but they also have a
trans gene that expresses stem cell
factor grandness like magnifiers
stimuli sector in Lukens three so they
have an aisle three
it's called calmly stimulating factor
two which is also known as gm-csf
and then they call it kit ligand but kit
ligand is also known as skin cell factor
and these are human specific cytokines
that can enhance the growth and
proliferation of the myeloid compartment
mast cells and the primitive human craft
like stem cell compartment so what we
did first is just compare the graph and
then graph in kinetics of these two
different platforms side by side so we
have female and SG mice and we have
female NS te s GMC lies as we call them
the mice were irradiated to prepare them
for the engraftment of these cells you
need to like you need to radiate these
mines which gives a competitive
advantage is by ablating the remaining
mouse cells in that pendant bone marrow
compartment and gives those donor cells
a competitive advantage for and graphing
input them proliferating out into the
peripheral lymphoid organs in the mice
we dosed the mice from cells obtained
from the exact same donor all of the
mice got about 130,000 cells and then we
collected blood at different time points
posted Rathman 2 6 9 12 15 18 etc weeks
after engraftment
and look for different markers okay so
what we're showing here is we're showing
that the SG m3 mice are shown in the red
squares as shown here excuse me money
changement marker okay so this is this
upper graph is the SG m3 mice and with
following totals human c-45 engraftment
all the time so the x-axis is weeks post
engraftment and what we're seeing here
is that the SG m3 mice have a more
robust expansion of the human donor
derived
scene 45 cells in the periphery over
time now if we look at the myeloid cells
expansion we see that the STM 3 mice
have a very robust and very
rapid expansion of the myeloid
compartment is indicated by Cu 33
myeloid positive cells in the peripheral
blood over time but what's interesting
is we notice is that over time the
overall engraftment of these cells
becomes similar between these two models
over time B cell compartment remains a
little bit more robust within the
regular NSG c 34 and grafted mice as
compared to the s 2 in 3 minds but the T
cell compartment is a little bit more
robust in the sgm 3 and so this
flip-flop between these two may be a
flat reflected at just the differences
in the percentages of these B cells and
T cells within the human cd45
compartment so if we go back and we look
at just the T cell compartment has shown
here if we just look at any C 3 T cell
compartment and we look at within that
human T cell compartment the frequency
of cd8 positive T cells seeing for
positive T cells and then a sub
compartment of the cd4 T cells called
the regulatory T cells the regulatory T
cells are cd4 positive C 25 positive and
positive for another market called Fox
peace free the regulatory T cells are
very important because they are
important for controlling and regulating
immune tolerance and as shown in the
literature
the NSG s TM 3 mice have a more robust
regulatory t-cell compartment and that
is reflected here within our graphic
models as well so there are more cd4
t-cells and are also more regulatory T
cells within the NSG s gm3 platform so
of course the next question we wanted to
ask was well do these mice these
humanized mice the STS GM 3 mice do they
also respond to standard of care drugs
and do they respond to immune or
modified drugs like Katrina and here's
our preliminary testing of this this is
a breast model that is PDL one positive
at about 70% in amongst mice do
have a response to both of these chemo
therapeutic agents they're shown here
and we can see that there is a
stabilized stabilization of disease or
prevention of tumor girls in this
platform now we've also tried some
combinatorial therapies and some other
things here we've also tried another in
a modular agent called your boy your boy
is a blockage of the CTL ctla4
co-stimulatory pathway that is supposed
to help release these t-cells from
managing energy as well we can see that
there was not quite as robust a response
in this particular model that we've only
tried one model so far this is a
long-term ER model but we do see that
there is some significant response when
you run the statistics on this we do see
some statistically significant responses
particularly would look at 21 days post
treatment so we're very encouraged by
this and we're going to be looking at
some different cognate oriole therapies
and we're going to be advancing
evaluation of these these different
chemotherapeutics in the future okay so
in summary the NSG are a proven platform
for the engraftment of human immune
system
PDX growth is not affected by HLA type
matching on this platform the tumor
growth kinetics are similar whether you
use humanized mice or non humanized mice
and we've looked at eight or nine
different PDX tumors to date and all of
them seem to have very high tumor take
rates and seem to grill very robustly on
the humanized mice the human immune
effector cells infiltrate the human
tumors and this is true both in the
human 6:13 form grafted NSG nice as well
as the SG m3 I didn't show you data for
that but we do
preliminary data showing that there's
infiltration of those tuners in that
floor platform as well
the Shu cd34 NS g and SG m3 PDX tumors
when transplanted onto those mines
respond quite nicely yeah particularly
to kick trigger and we're going to be
use this as a testing platform for
looking at as a human auditory and
oncology agents as well and just to wrap
up I'd like to acknowledge my colleagues
at the Jackson Laboratory who did this
work I just have the privilege
presenting this data to you today the
work was performed by several key
workers in our Imperial pharmacology
services group headed by dr. James Keck
dr. Karolina palooka she works at her
the Jax genomic medicine site we now
have a dedicated human genomic medicine
site down in Connecticut she's a
researcher who is focused entirely on
human genetics and human cancer immuno
oncology and she's helping us in
assisting us with a lot of this data we
also I would like to recognize dr. Lenny
Schultz who has was the creator of the
NSG Meissen who has a number of
collaborations with folks like Dale
Greiner and Michael Bradley you massenet
etc so with that I'd like to say thank
you very much for attending and I'd be
happy to answer some questions
excellent presentation dr. Sopher thanks
for bringing that information to us
before we get started on all of your
questions here's a quick reminder about
how to reach us today questions can be
sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll get to as many questions as we can
and give it a few moments
our first question is from yang @ui lily
and the question is what's minimal in
number for the studies okay thank you
for that question that's an excellent
one we advise most of our clients that
are coming to us doing these kinds of
studies to have an N of 10 we realize
that this is not an inexpensive model to
work with and we do do some studies with
as low as an anime but we strongly feel
for statistical significance that in n
of 10 is most appropriate remember that
these are heterologous tumours so we do
see some variability and so we do
recommend an end of 10th of each of the
study arms that are conducted okay we'll
give you another moment if there are no
more questions I would like to once
again thank dr. Soper for his
presentation do you have any final
comments dr. Soper oh hogs one second um
hold that thought
another question from yang Eli Willie
have you used to virus in those models
such as adenovirus or AAV
question sorry about that now I have my
voice yes that's an excellent question
we are beginning to get questions about
that there's a number of different
things that people would like to do they
would like to do things like use
adenovirus or AZ to introduce modulatory
agents of course there's things like the
Karthik technology modifying t-cell
receptors people want to do things like
label the cells as they can fouled up
expressing molecules like luciferase
molecules and things like that so since
this is an earlier area of research
we're just beginning to take on some of
those studies right now
we don't have it as an established
platform but we are taking on those
studies from time to time and we're
doing Rob we would call sponsored
studies so that if someone wanted to
test those kind of platforms we're
willing to take those on and give them
and give them a try and we have a number
of ongoing experiments like that at the
present
taani from the University of Toledo asks
with the PDX database is their genomic
cnv data available yes that's a great
question yes there is there's copy
number variation data there's gene
variant data so there's characterization
of different specific mutations that you
can look through in addition to the gene
expression data so all of that stuff is
there and if there's something very
specific that you're looking for that
you're not finding there's a link that
you can contact us and we will try to
dig up some of that data for you we can
do some different types of analyses and
look for some things so please get in
contact with us if you have more
questions about that I would like to
once again thank dr. Soper for his
presentation do you have any final
comments to share with us dr. Sopher yes
thank you I'd just like to thank the
organizers for giving this opportunity
to present this data this is a this is a
very exciting field and there's a lot of
information being collected this is an
active area of really kind of
cutting-edge research and if you have
questions about this I just want to say
that we do have a new vivo services
group that obviously is making these
mice available to the scientific
community
we're also doing studies in house where
if you do not have the platform
established in your mouth so you're not
having your mouse room or new well if
you could I have a vivarium maybe you're
a biochemist or an immunologist that
does not have access to the vivarium we
can work with you with these different
platforms to test your different agents
and do some different experiments with
them so I'd like to thank everyone for
joining us today and I really appreciate
the time I would also like to thank you
again dr. Sopher and I would also like
to thank our sponsor the Jackson
Laboratory making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
March 30th 2016 you'll receive an email
from us alerting you when it's available
on demand and posted on labyrinth comm
you're welcome to forward this
announcement to any colleagues who
aren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast see you next time